[Applause]
thank you thank you for being here thank
you to everyone who is getting behind my
campaign
now
in the last few days i have been
undertaking the parliamentary equivalent
of speed dating
i've had a lot of good conversations
with a lot of wonderful colleagues
and i've learned a few things
i've learned that many of them were
counsellors before they came into
parliament
many of them work for voluntary
organizations
many of them have run businesses and
some still do
many of them are still pulling a shift
in our nhs
many of them serving our armed forces
and our veterans
they're people that want to serve their
country
they're people that want to step up and
take responsibility
and when i meet people like that
i want to know why
why do they do that why do they want to
take responsibility
was it some experience in their life was
it an
inspirational person that they met
and when did it happen
and for me
it was when i was nine years old
and i was standing on the hot walls in
portsmouth
watching the falklands task force leave
portsmouth harbour
now i didn't know much about that scene
at nine years old
but witnessing it
and thatcher's resolve at the time
well i knew my country stood up to
bullies
[Applause]
and i knew that that was important
important enough
for some of those warships
and my classmates fathers not to return
home
i'd seen duty
and service
and sacrifice for something greater than
ourselves
and it's the reason why today when
people ask me about britain and our role
in the world
i say we don't need a new role in the
world
we just need to be ourselves
we feel these values keenly
it's why we serve as parliamentarians
they're the values of our party
and they're the values of our country
too
our greatest moments
have been when we have been the living
embodiment of those values
and our greatest failures were when we
came adrift from them
recently
i think our party
has lost its sense of self
if i can compare it to being in the
glastonbury audience when paul mccartney
was playing his set
we indulged all those new tunes but what
we really wanted was the good old stuff
that we all knew the words to
low tax
small state
personal responsibility
[Applause]
we need to get back to that because
we've got some really serious challenges
ahead
we've got to stave off a recession
we've got to deliver on the huge
ambition that the british people have
having left the european union
we've got to catch up after covid
we have a war
and we have a manifesto to deliver
and standards and trust to restore
[Music]
and the british people are fed up
they're fed up with us not delivering
they're fed up with unfulfilled promises
and they're fed up with divisive
politics
so how do we turn this around
well first of all
we have to admit that whitehall is
broken
there are great people that work there
but in my administration you will see it
look and feel very different
very fast
we need to do some serious machinery of
government changes
we're going to have a tighter cabinet
we're going to have ministers of state
that have clear and timely deliverables
and are powerful and can reach across
whitehall
and we're going to modernize government
with the white heat of modernization
we need to move at the speed that
business and science needs us to
secondly
we need to build a modern economy
now you'll have heard pictures this week
on tax and spend
i'm going to talk about growth
and competition
my key fiscal rule is that debt as a
percentage of gdp will fall over time
my monetary policy will be on
controlling inflation and our supply
side reforms will yield a brexit
dividend on investment infrastructure
incentives and innovation
[Applause]
and we also
need to let our citizens live well
for me you're going to get a relentless
focus on cost of living issues
i've already announced that on day one
we are going to slash
vat on fuel at the pump by half
and we are going to raise income tax
thresholds for basic and middle income
earners in line with inflation
but we also need to extract more value
for example through simplifying and
reducing the cost of being tax compliant
for our citizens and for business
and we need to get things to work better
i'm going to be putting
power back into the hands of parents
we are going to create
personal budgets to allow every child
access to their entitlements to
subsidize child care
at any time prior to them starting full
time
and we are going to create some task
forces to get a grip on the crisis and
paralysis in accessing nhs services and
dentists
[Applause]
and also and vitally stagnation in house
building
fourthly
if we are really serious about leveling
up
we cannot be limited in our ambition
by what is in the treasury's coffers
we have to get real about this
so i want to align government planning
cycles with those of business and the
charity sector which are already aligned
and that will give us
huge opportunities to co-fund to form
partnerships to do more for our citizens
and we need some national missions in
this country that the whole country and
every sector can get behind
and i also want to set up some social
capital pots that mps themselves can
administer you guys are best placed in
your communities to spot those gaps and
spot the opportunities and i want to
give you more agency to serve your
communities
[Music]
[Music]
and finally
i want all of our citizens to be able to
live in safety and security
i'm committing to our manifesto
commitment on defense spending and our
nato
spending pledge
but i am also going to remove
some of the strains on our armed forces
and take tasks from them that they don't
need to do
and so i'm going to stand up a civil
defense force as i outlined when i
rewrote this country's resilience
strategy
and i want us to consolidate and
capitalize on the huge amount of civic
action there was during the pandemic all
those volunteers that came forward to
make our country the most resilient
nation on earth
my country
and our party
has been through a lot in the last few
years
but we have stamina
make no mistake about that
in that moment of crisis during the
pandemic
the british public stepped forward
they were moved by the values of this
country too
they are capable
and responsible people
they expect their government to be to
they expect us
to deliver on both the mandate
and the majority
they handed us
i can and we will
[Applause]